so your Ignus symbolize a Hungarian
doctor working in a hospital in Vienna
Austria in 1846 assanted the obstetrics
Ward you help mothers give birth and you
treat them in their newborns for
diseases and in 1846 there was no
disease mothers and doctors feared more
than the dread appear Pro fever within
three days of giving birth a woman with
pre-operable fever would experience
severe abdominal pain fever debility and
eventually death by the time you joined
the hospital in Vienna around 13 to 18
of all new mothers in the ward were
dying from Pure Pro fever more than ever
before and no one could figure out why
you see back in the 1800s medicine
looked very different from what it is
today doctors didn't know anything about
bacteria or viruses they believed that
all illnesses were caused by bad odors
and miasmas that's right bad odors and
that you could Cure Disease by letting
leeches suck out your tainted blood to
make things even more confusing the
hospital you worked at also had another
award for women to give birth this Ward
was for the poor people that couldn't
afford a trained physician so it was
staffed by midwives not doctors Midwest
or women who are trained to help other
women give birth so even though midwives
only had a fraction of the training of
doctors their mortality rate for the
fever was more than five times lower so
that begs the question why were the
doctors worse at their jobs compared to
these untrained midwives desperate to
discover what was killing your patients
you started carefully watching the two
words first you thought the difference
was that the women in The Midwives Ward
gave birth on their sides while the
doctors had women give birth on their
backs so he told the doctors to let
women give birth on the sides instead
but it made no difference next she
noticed that whenever someone died of
the fever a priest would walk through
the war with unattended following him
who was ringing a bell maybe the sound
of the Bell was so terrifying that it
scared women into getting sick so you
told the priest to ditch the bell and
change his route through the ward but
that didn't help either eventually you
became so frustrated by the problem that
you decided to take a break from your
work and spend a little time abroad you
returned home to some bad news one of
your close doctor friends at the Vienna
hospital had died while doing an autopsy
on a woman who died from the pureful
fever he had cut his finger on a scalpel
and a little later he died from the same
disease as the woman he had autopsied
and that's when it hit you pure apple
fever wasn't something that only woman
could get other people could get it too
and even more surprising just like how
your friend had died soon after touching
organs affected by the fever and cutting
his hand so what if it was these germs
we'll call them that was transferring
the fever to others it made complete
sense while the midwives only assistant
in births the doctors in the other Ward
would often carry out autopsies with
their bare hands before going right back
to a sustaining birth without washing
their hands if you were right then
having doctors wash their hands was the
key to preventing the spread of the
fever so you ordered your stuff to start
cleaning their hands and instruments
with a chlorine solution you didn't know
chlorine was a powerful disinfectant
back then you just thought it would get
rid of the smell left behind by the
autopsies and boom within months of
implementing your new hand washing
requirements the number of mothers dying
from the fever in your ward dropped by
around seven times to this same rate as
The Midwives Ward it was a breakthrough
you had finally figured it out here was
a proven way to save lives just wash
your hands and you couldn't wait to
share your findings with the rest of the
hospital but unfortunately instead of
being praised for your new discovery you
were met with extreme backlash and when
he wrote a paper explaining what he was
doing the other doctors actually came
after him and his boss I can't remember
his name but but I can find him for you
but his boss actually said something to
the effect of stop bringing all this
newfangled stuff if you if it wasn't
good enough for our father for our
forefathers and it's not good enough for
us the other doctors thought you were
crazy wash your hands what was this
woo-woo nonsense hand washing was for
getting rid of bad smells or dirt not
health and yet here you were saying that
invisible particles on doctor's hands
were killing people it was ridiculous so
the doctors refused to wash their hands
they refused to listen to your crackery
it didn't matter that they had seen
firsthand that hand washing worked you
were going against everything they
believed and everything that they were
taught who were you to have known better
than every other doctor out there and
this back left you Furious you were so
angry you told your superiors that they
were the ones that were killing the
mothers and technically you weren't
wrong but accusing them of murder till
their faces didn't go over very well and
so you were eventually fired all for
trying to get people to wash their hands
the anger the stress of losing your job
and the guilt over all the people you
could have saved sent you into a
complete mental breakdown in 1865 and so
you were admitted to a mental Asylum
where you died shortly after a cut on
your henna become infected causing
untreatable septus the very same thing
that killed all those women that you
were trying to save decades later
doctors and researchers developed the
germ theory of disease that it was in
fact bacteria and viruses that cause
illnesses not odors and miasmas and it
was only in depth that you were
celebrated as a hero too bad you weren't
around to see it in 1998 it became
standard of care for doctors to wash
their hands you go back before that and
there were doctors that washed their
hands and it was becoming more and more
of a practice but it was actually AIDS
in the hep C crisis that actually drove
those regulations to be changed to
require them to make a standard of care
for doctors to wash their hands between
sick patients if the doctors had all
been doing it they wouldn't have had to
go in and say okay this is standard of
care now this is Nate Jones by the way
the CEO and founder of clear wooden X he
spent his life learning about
preventative medicine and what he
realized is that the backlash Ignus
simulvas got for telling people to wash
their hands wasn't just some one-off
thing in fact this is what oftentimes
happens when there's a medical
advancement including today whenever
someone discovers a new treatment a new
way of thinking a new advancement that
could save countless of lives The
Establishment fights back the doctors
and Regulators that sit in their Ivory
Towers fight back all to maintain the
status quo but why and what are they
hiding from us today stay dangerous and
this is why Western medicine is so
backwards
the perfect example of medical
advancements getting suppressed was with
this recent pandemic that we just had
during this pandemic studies found that
a simple 10 nasal spray was saline and
Xylitol had a positive effect on
treating the virus and that the Xylitol
in this nasal spray actually deactivates
respiratory viruses Nate's company
clears sold this nasal spray but when
Nate's company tried to share these
scientifically back claims to save lives
the government barred them from doing so
why would the government do that well
we'll let you take a guess that's why
Nate wanted to sponsor this video to
help get the word out about this clear
sailing Xylitol nasal spray is super
affordable it's the best on the market
you can find it in stores like CVS
Walgreens most grocery stores or by
clicking the link below we'll go over
more of it later but cleaning your nose
with a nasal spray is something that we
should all be doing every single day
just like how you brush your teeth every
day and I learned this first hand
recently someone close to me had a
really nasty cough and then I started
picking up the cough as well so all I
did was use this nasal spray a few times
a day and then the cough went away so
click the link below and pick up some
clear now
ha
this is Dr Sarah Joe Baker and unlike
ignacemovas she lived in a time when
germ Theory had already been proven by
then most doctors knew that it was germs
that caused diseases but the types of
germs of War they came from were still
up for debates Dr Joe was one of the
first female doctors to be trained in
America and in 1908 she was put in
charge of New York's Bureau of child
hygiene her job would be to try to
improve the health of America's children
but unlike the people around her thought
their jail wasn't interested in treating
kids after they got sick no she wanted
to focus on preventing diseases in
children and she would do that by
teaching New Yorkers basic hygiene and
in the early 1900s her biggest challenge
laid in New York's poorest and most
crowded districts Hell's Kitchen you see
even though doctors knew about germ
Theory very few regular people
understood that hygiene was important
for health and with so many immigrants
flooding into New York from all over the
world it felt almost impossible to get
the message across by the time Dr Joe
took charge 1 500 babies were dying
every week in the summer just from
diarrhea something had to be done so Dr
Joe went on the offensive first she
ensured that every new mother in The
District was visited at least once by a
nurse so that they can learn some basic
newborn care and hygiene some of the
things she taught like encouraging
breastfeeding washing your hands regular
bathing and getting fresh air into your
home may seem obvious to us now but the
people who didn't know better Dr Joe's
new policies were literal Lifesavers and
they produce almost immediate results
one thousand fewer babies died in house
catching than expected while the
mortality rate everywhere else stayed
the same but Dr Joe wasn't done yet over
the next few years she made it a
requirement for midwives to be licensed
waiting out women who are incompetent or
untrained she set up baby Health
stations to distribute clean milk
instead of the beer or dirty water
mothers would give their children by
1911 the infant death rate in New York
had dropped by 40 percent today Dr Joe
is seen as a hero who saved the lives of
90 000 children in New York and possibly
Millions more because her policies were
copied in other states and countries but
not everyone saw Dr Joe as the hero she
was because by saving lives and
preventing diseases she was ruining the
business of New York doctors who were
lied on sick babies to make money think
about it those doctors were in the
business of treating disease not
preventing it and Dr Joe was trampling
on their business some of them hated Dr
Joe so much that they went to the mayor
to tell him to shut her down luckily the
numbers spoke for themselves and the
mayor refused by the time Dr Joe left
her job all 48 states in America had a
bureau of child health just like the one
in New York but other Innovative doctors
aren't so lucky but why why is it that
time and time again doctors always seem
to fight back against progress against
saving lives it's because of one word
ego
[Music]
today one of the main reasons people
become doctors is because of the money
the average doctor today earns around
265 000 a year but back in the days of
ignis semovas becoming a doctor was not
a great financial decision most doctors
will only make a few dollars per patient
and there wasn't always a lot of work to
go around so money was never really the
issue but ego definitely was back in the
1800s a doctor's reputation was
everything if you were the head of a
hospital or Department no one was
supposed to be smarter or no better than
you so when new Young doctors like ignis
came in claiming to know better than
doctors who had been around for decades
they had to be shut down it didn't
matter if these new discoveries were
rights it only mattered that the right
person discovered it and over the years
doctors started earning a lot more money
by the 1900s becoming inductive met you
would live comfortably for the rest of
your life but there was still a problem
without sick people doctors wouldn't
make anything and that's where
organizations like the American Medical
Association come in they say that ama is
there to promote the science and art of
Medicine and the betterment of Public
Health but in reality the AMA is just
like any other cartel out there they are
there to protect the interests of their
Members First which means making sure
that doctors keep making a lot of money
which naturally aligns with treating
diseases not preventing them I think
it's because they're afraid of
preventative of ways to keep their
people the people healthy because if
they're healthy they're not the doctors
aren't going to be making money and the
organization is is put in place to make
sure that they continue to make money if
doctors were being trained to keep us
healthy which is what we believe what
they're doing but if they were actually
keeping us healthy we'd wouldn't we'd
have way too many doctors but the fact
is is they're not doing a good job
they're phenomenal at once you're sick
helping you get better from acute issues
but they really suck at keeping us
healthy we're the most obese population
on the country we're the most unhealthy
you know we have all kinds of Health
Care issues and if doctors were out
there pushing and helping us to stay
healthy we want to need as many doctors
because we want to be getting sick as
often and to be clear no one is saying
that there's a secret cabal of doctors
sitting in a dimly lit room making sure
that people get sicker and sicker but
that is just the natural outcome of
these incentives my children you know
you said you didn't have any kids but
most people accept that their kids are
going to get sick
from time to time that is not I don't
believe that that's true they shouldn't
we aren't geared we aren't made to be
sick we're made to be healthy and unless
something's wrong with us or we're doing
something wrong to ourselves we
shouldn't be sick and my kids I mean
they're the they're the you know they're
your average kid other than I make them
wash their nose and I actually make them
real food they they eat junk food they
eat processed food but I would say they
probably eat a quarter of what your
average kid eats my 12 year old who's
been sick of probably a grand total of
maybe 10 days in her life and my 10 year
old has never been sick a day in your
life she doesn't know what it's like to
be sick at all whoa that's crazy normal
kids usually get sick at least once a
year right no they actually get sick
four times a year wow and your kids have
not gotten sick well one of them hasn't
gone sick at all my deathly ill child
has been sick a total of 10 days and my
kids have traveled all over the world
they've been to India with me they've
been to Australia they've been all over
Latin America they've been all over
Africa they've been all over Europe you
would think that they would get sick and
how did imagine not letting his kids get
part of it is the obvious stuff like
less junk food and less processed foods
but the other secret is something that
the medical community has been
suppressing or at least woefully
ignoring cleaning your nose
[Music]
cleaning your nose nasal hygiene is
sounds so simple and random but it's
actually something that we should all be
doing why because breathing is the most
important thing you can do think about
it every day you breathe in around 11
000 liters of air which is about half of
one of these tanker trucks but while
we're all happy to wash our hands or
brush our teeth we do nothing to protect
and care for the one organ that's
responsible for taking in the air we
need to live people think it's more
important to wash your hands but
actually it's more important to wash
your nose because if you're going to get
a virus sir a cold or anything that's
going to multiply in your nose so
squirting your nose with a clear nasal
spray washes the nose it cleans out dust
dirt pollen bacteria and viruses it
actually coats the nose to make it
easier to breathe through the nose it
also pulls out fluid if the nose is
congested this is Trisha O'Hare a dental
hygienist 50 years and the president of
O'Hare University and our modern lives
of air conditioning and breathing in not
clean air just makes it all that much
worse I mean your nose is actually a
really phenomenal mechanism for cleaning
the air we breathe
I mean you you breathe in you've got you
know I don't want to get too gross but I
mean you got snot you got mucus and it
traps all kinds of things and it has
compounds in it that actually kill
bacteria that kill viruses all of these
things the pH of your mucus is actually
acidic so that it kills some of these
viruses and bacteria but a lot of the
things that that we're doing in our life
today cause us to be chronically
dehydrated we drink a lot of coffee we
drink a lot of caffeine caffeine is a
diuretic it dehydrates us okay we're
working in air-conditioned buildings or
heated buildings all of that air is
dried out all of those things cause us
to have more upper respiratory issues
than what we should be having and if you
get congested and you go to the doctor
and say hey I'm all stuffed up what does
the doctor tell you to do they tell you
to use a decongestant or a nasal steroid
they put you on on fluticism you know on
one of these things and all of those
products are actually geared to shut
down your immune system I mean your body
creating mucus your body creating snot
is actually your immune system
responding to what it thinks is a threat
if you're breathing in a virus or a
bacteria your body wants to get that out
of your out of the air before it gets to
your lungs what does it do it makes more
snot ear infections sinus infections
colds flus covid allergies asthma is a
disease of the lung but the triggers
enter through your nose all of these
things start in the nose it just makes
sense that we should be discussing how
to wash our nose and the best way to
wash your nose is with something called
Xylitol xylitol is a natural sugar
alcohol found in many fruits and
vegetables but when you apply it to your
nose the Xylitol sits in your snot it
blocks bacterial adhesion and blocks
viral adhesion and it also osmotically
is going to pull moisture out of the
tissue which is the egg and reduce
inflammation and open the airway the
other thing it's going to do is
facilitate the Cilia moving the mucus
away from
your nose and yet no one talks about it
why because as we mentioned doctors are
in the business of preventing disease
they're in the business of treating
disease that's where their head is at so
naturally they're not going to pay
attention to stuff like this that's why
after realizing all of this Nate's dad
Dr Lon Jones created a Xylitol nasal
spray to treat his patients the results
were so incredible that in the year 2000
they created clear to make the same
Xylitol spray available to everyone
um I recommend obviously I recommend our
nasal spray because I think it's the
best one on the market you can find it
at CVS you can buy it find it at
Walgreens most of your grocery stores
your pharmacies your natural ritos but
find a nasal spray that has Xylitol in
it and you just spray it up your nose
when you brush your teeth in the morning
wash your nose it's a hygiene tool
okay or not it's not a drug it's not a
pharmaceutical it's a hygiene tool to
help I mean the same way we brush our
teeth the same way we use mouthwash the
same way we take a shower hopefully the
same way we wash our hands all we're
doing is we're actually just helping our
body we're washing our nose cleaning
cleaning contaminants debris all that
stuff out of our nose after Nick
explained it to me like this I started
washing my nose with clear every day as
well I do it in the morning when I brush
my teeth and it's actually way easier
than brushing your teeth you just pump
the spray in each nostril and you're
done what's great about clears that is
super affordable and like Nate mentioned
you can find it everywhere so I highly
recommend you guys pick some up we'll
link it below so scroll down and click
the link below to pick up some now
[Music]
thank you